hey 42 here in 1993 a Missouri man
purposely damaged a levee on the
Mississippi River to delay his wife
coming home from work so he could party
drink and have an affair the river
flooded 14,000 acres of land he was
later arrested and convicted of causing
a catastrophe and sentenced to a life in
prison welcome to RIF the Navy is now
teaching sailors celestial navigation as
a response to potential cyber attacks to
ships navigation systems there are a
class of people in Japan referred to as
cyber homeless who live at cyber cafes
because they are a cheaper alternative
than an apartment the cafes offer free
showers and sell underware Swedish blood
donors receive a thank-you text after
they donate blood but they also receive
a text whenever their blood is used to
help someone there is a Santa Claus
University that teaches professional
Santa Claus skills like toy knowledge
poses and how to avoid lawsuits a
top-level Santa Clause can make up to
$100,000 a year writing was likely only
invented from scratch three times in
history in the Middle East China and
Central America all other alphabets and
writing systems were either derived from
or inspired by others or were too
incompletes
to fully express the spoken language in
1941 the world's largest seed bank
created by botanist Nikolay Vavilov was
housed in Leningrad as the Germans
surrounded the city forcing a mass
starvation
Vavilov scientists refused to eat from
the seed collection instead slowly dying
of hunger as they maintained 16 rooms of
edible plants if Apple didn't hold 181
billion dollars overseas it would owe
fifty nine billion dollars in u.s.
a man from New Zealand named Nigel
Richards memorized a French dictionary
to win the French Scrabble championship
he can't speak French but was able to
correct his opponent when they attempted
to play an incorrect word more than
1,000 experts including Stephen Hawking
Elon Musk and Steve Wozniak assigned an
open letter urging a global ban on AI
weapons systems when the USS West
Virginia was finally raised after being
sunk during the bombing of Pearl Harbor
three deceased men were found in an
air-tight store room on the calendar 16
days were crossed off in red pencil a
norwegian student named Christopher Koch
spent $27 on bitcoins and forgot about
them a few years later he realized they
were worth eight hundred and eighty six
thousand dollars a New Zealand trucker
fell onto a high-pressure air valve it
punctured his left foot and inflated him
to twice his size nearly killing him he
survived but it took three days to fart
and burp out the excess air Lenovo CEO
Yang Yuanqing
receives a free million dollar bonus as
a reward for record profits in 2012
which he in turn redistributed to about
10,000 of Lenovo's employees he made a
similar gift again of three point two
five million dollars in 2013 Indian
housewives hold 11% of the world's gold
that is more than the reserves of the
USA IMF Switzerland and Germany put
together for his time as James Bond
Daniel Craig has the privilege of taking
any Aston Martin from the factory for
the rest of his life
the lucky
during the process of becoming a
butterfly the entire caterpillar will
break down into a liquid to be a London
black cab driver one is expected to know
over 25,000 roads and 50,000 points of
interest
and pass a test called the knowledge
capacity example applicants usually need
12 appearances and 34 months of
preparation in 1956 the US government
said many containers of beer next to two
atomic bombs that were detonated to
determine if the beer was still
drinkable their conclusion in the event
of a nuclear war beer is perfectly safe
to drink in Russia during times of
economic disparity or high inflation
teachers in the remote region were paid
in vodka in an out burger used to light
customers add as many extra patties with
cheese as they wanted to their burgers
until one group of eight people ordered
one burger with a hundred patties which
contained 19 thousand 490 calories minut
bomb the tallest player in the history
of the NBA was also the only player in
the NBA to have killed a lion with a
spear and who have paid 80 cows for his
wife in 2010 a man who is lost in the
woods of northern Saskatchewan Canada
chopped down some power lines so that
workmen would have to come and rescue
him the rhinoceros party was a
registered political party in Canada
between the 1960s and 90s it was led by
Cornelius a rhinoceros and promised to
repeal a law of gravity and change
Canada's currency to border so it could
be inflated or deflated at will in 1976
an underachieving Princeton junior
undergraduate wrote a term paper
describing how to make a nuclear bomb he
got an A but never got his paper back
because it was seized by the FBI in
October of 1994 book fiction Forrest
Gump the Shawshank Redemption
and Jurassic Park were all in the
theaters at the same time in Japan there
is a hotel that has been in business for
more than 1300 years and all that time
it has been operated by the same family
for 46 generations
according to NASA nuclear power has
prevented over two million deaths in the
past 40 years as a result of lower air
pollution from reduced coal usage on
Titan the atmosphere is so thick and the
gravity so low that humans could fly
through it by flapping homemade wings
attached to their arms Charles Pretty
Boy Floyd a Great Depression era
gangster and notorious bank robber
endeared himself to the public by
destroying mortgage papers at the banks
he rocked freeing many from adepts in
1808 a gentleman's duel took place at
2,000 feet in a pair of hot-air balloons
each man used a blunderbuss to attempt
to destroy the others balloon a survey
found that 28% of IT professionals hide
their career from family and friends out
of fear of being asked to provide free
tech support in 2005 a 12 year old girl
was abducted in Ethiopia and her captors
tried to force her into an arranged
marriage she was rescued by three lions
who defended her for free days from her
attackers when a massive power outage
struck Southern California in the 1990s
Los Angeles residents reportedly called
9-1-1 to express alarm about strange
clouds hovering overhead they were
seeing the Milky Way for the first time
sheeeit sheep don't recognize each other
and fight for a few days afterwards to
re-establish hierarchy when Stephen
Hawking gave a lecture in Japan he was
asked not to mention the possible we
collapse of the universe billions of
years into the future for fears of the
effects it would have on the stock
exchange the Mexican drug cartels have
we
we've been kidnapping technicians and
making them build their own private cell
phone network in Mexico a man earned
four million airline miles for free
without breaking any laws by using his
credit card to purchase free delivery $1
coins from the US Mint if a dead whale
is found on a British Beach then by law
the head belongs to the king and the
tail to the Queen Houston Airport
received a lot of complaints about
baggage wait times in response they move
the package claim area further away so
that the walk was longer than the wait
subsequently the number of complaints
dropped significantly when people are
electrocuted and thrown far distances it
is the result of sudden and violent
muscle contractions it is not caused by
the shock itself this has raised
questions as to the actual strength and
capabilities of the muscles inside the
human body in 2006 David Copperfield
used sleight of hands to trick armed
robbers into believing he had nothing on
him even though he was carrying his
passport wallet and cell phone ernest
hemingway took a urinal from his
favorite bar and moved it into his Key
West home arguing that he had pissed
away so much of his money into the
urinal that he owned it killing season
is a British medical term used to
describe the time around August when the
newly qualified doctors joined the
National Health Service during the siege
of Jerusalem 1917 the British in an
effort to captured a city from an
entrenched Ottoman garrison started to
airdrop cigarettes filled with large
doses of opium hoping that the Ottomans
would be to stones to fight it worked
until it was forcibly suppressed during
World War one German was the second most
spoken language in the US with many
local government schools and newspapers
operating in German in 2011 researchers
led 200 paper planes go from 23 miles
above Germany some have since been found
in can
America Australia South Africa samuel
l.jackson has a clause in all his movie
contracts stating that he gets two days
off a week to play golf and the
producers have to pay for it will take
76 days for the average person to read
all the terms and conditions they agree
to in a year
PC pitstop a software company buried a
$1,000 prize deep within its Terms of
Service to see if anyone actually read
them after five months and over 3,000
sales later someone eventually claimed
the prize contrary to popular belief Las
Vegas is far from the gambling capital
of the world
McDowell's gambling revenue is a
whopping five times larger an American
man named Mike Merrill decided to sell
shares in himself at $1 a share with
100,000 shares up for grabs in total
allowing his stockholders to decide what
he should do with his life in 1942 there
was a man known as the Phantom barber he
would break into people's houses in
Mississippi at night and cut their hair
until the 1980s physicians routinely
operated on infants without any
anesthetic administering only muscle
relaxants to prevent motion under the
belief that infants could not feel pain
in 2006 a man from Portland Oregon hired
a hit man to kill his wife
his wife ended up killing the hit man
with her bare hands
despite the world's hottest chili
peppers growing 2 million Scoville heat
units there is another hotter cactus
called euphorbia resin ephraim that
produces a resin that hits an estimated
16 billion scovilles in 2000 a mexican
woman named anneza ramirez paris
successfully performed a c-section on
herself after 12 hours of continuous
pain with a kitchen knife and three
glasses of hard spirits whilst her
husband was out drinking at a bar
an albatross can sleep whilst it flies
hummingbirds
can't walk their legs are too small and
weak at 120 miles per hour a Formula One
car generates so much downforce that it
could drive upside down on the roof of a
tunnel if you're in Detroit and you walk
south you'll actually walk into Canada
the stickers on fruit are edible they
are usually made out of edible paper and
even the glue holding it to the fruit is
food grade black roses do exist but they
only grow in exceptionally small numbers
in the Turkish village of Health Fetty
this is the only place in the world that
they will grow due to the unique
properties of the soil caused by the
nearby Euphrates River you're completely
blind for about 40 minutes a day when
your eyes move your brain purposely
blocked your vision to avoid blurring
which is why you can't see the motion of
your rivals in a mirror it's called
saccadic masking and without it your
life would be like watching a constant
movie that's filmed of a shaky handheld
camera in ancient Greece throwing an
apple at someone was a way of declaring
your love for them during the 18th
century you could pay your admission to
the London Zoo by bringing in a dog or a
cats to feed to the Lions Russian
mathematician
Grigori Perelman solves a 100 year old
math problem called the Poincare
conjecture he declined the Fields Medal
and 1 million dollars in awards because
he hated the recognition that the mass
community gives to people who prove
things it is illegal to not flush the
toilet in Singapore if you fail to flush
you'll be forking out over a hundred and
fifty dollars in fines
what's more police officers have been
known to check
in France by law a bakery has to make
all the bread it sells from scratch in
order to have the right to be called a
baker in China if you hit someone with
your car you must pay for their medical
care for the rest of their life however
if you kill someone with your car you
only pay a one-time thing for this
reason it is fairly common for people to
go back and kill someone they
accidentally hit NASA hires a man to
sniff everything that they send into
space if he doesn't like the smell it
doesn't go into space this job might
sound strange but should not be
underestimated nasty smells can be
extremely hazardous when you're stuck in
a small cabin for months with no windows
in the Chinese city of Chongqing
cellphone addicts have their own
sidewalk way more people drown in
deserts than die of dehydration because
when it rains in a desert it rains when
does it rain storms do happen they are
extremely violent
on average United States Congress brings
up Hitler 7.7 times per month you exert
more energy when you unfold a single
piece of paper none in all the radio
waves we have ever collected from outer
space Samsung is responsible for 25% of
South Korea's GDP some Canadian police
departments give out positive tickets to
thank people for doing good the first
person to be sentenced to the stocks in
Boston with Edward Palmer the person who
built the stocks his crime was charging
too much for building the stocks when
the princess and the frog came out in
cinemas 50 children were hospitalized
with Salmonella from kissing frogs in
Holland's Embassy in Moscow two Siamese
cats kept meowing and clawing at the
walls of the building their owners
finely investigated thinking they would
find mice instead they found microphones
hidden by Russian spies
in 1985 a man from New Orleans drowned
at a party attended by a hundred
lifeguards the party was to celebrate
going an entire summer without a
drowning in a city pool when you get a
kidney transplant it's more common to
just leave your original kidneys in your
body and put the third kidney in your
pelvis in the early 1900's a wave of
molasses rushed through the streets of
Boston at 35 miles-per-hour killing 21
people and injuring 150 it has since
been named the Boston molasses cosmic
rays from outer space cause glitches in
your electronics in some electronics
cosmic rays are the primary source of
software errors cosmic rays are one of
the main reasons that servers and high
reliability computers use error
correcting ground if a tree is low on a
particular type of nutrient it will
borrow some from its neighboring trees
pirate roots and then give the nutrients
back at a later date this happens more
often in the winter months they used to
exist a flying reptile that was as tall
as a giraffe called a Quetzalcoatlus in
Australia in 1932 there is a war called
the emu war the Australian military
tried to fight off emus that were
running amuck across Western Australia
using machine guns the emus would French
writer guida Masson pour ate lunch in
the restaurant inside the eiffel tower
almost every day because he hated the
tower and that was the only place in
Paris where he couldn't see it
u.s. scientists calculated that Santa
would have to visit 822 homes a second
to deliver all presents on Christmas Eve
but he is to say he can't America has a
four billion dollar stockpile of milk
fat for cheese and butter that is
sitting in a cave in Missouri during the
First Opium War of 1839 nineteen
thousand British troops fought against
200,000 Chinese the Chinese are 20,000
casual
tee's the British just 69 this marked
the start of the so-called century of
humiliation in China
Microsoft has created three billionaires
and roughly 12,000 millionaires in 1929
the US Supreme Court voted 8 to 1 in
favor of a eugenics program requiring
forced sterilization of citizens deemed
not smart enough to reproduce Marion
webmaster added McJob to their
dictionaries defined us a low-paying job
that requires little skill and provides
little opportunity for advancement
mcdonnell's
asked for it to be removed to which they
replied we stand by the accuracy and
appropriateness of our definition
Starbucks pays more for its employees
health insurance than it pays for coffee
during the filming of Bharat's the FBI
assigned a team to follow such a
baron-cohen due to countless reports of
a middle-eastern mountain traveling the
Midwest in an ice cream truck porn sites
are the sites you're statistically least
likely to get malware from due to them
being strictly monitored because malware
is bad for repeat business on the other
hand you're most likely to get malware
from religious sites a study found that
the average religious website is
infected with 115 malware friends
just 24 rabbits were set loose into a
stream within 67 years their population
had grown to 10 billion years a
geographical isolation has left
Australia with no natural predators
through the rabbit they migrated across
Australia at a rate of 18 miles year
there are still completely unexplored
passages inside the Great Pyramid of
Giza
in 1847 a doctor named Robert Liston
performed an amputation in 25 seconds
operating so quickly that an
accidentally amputated his assistants
fingers as well both later died of
sepsis and a spectator reported and died
a shock to date this is the only known
medical procedure to have a 300 percent
mortality and finally if you could fold
a piece of paper in half 42 times it
would reach the moon and if you could
fold it 103 times it would be as thick
as the observable universe thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42